je m'appelle isabelle et oui et comme
région sont venus j'étais suppl et comme
je cumule je suis né un 13
si on adopte alassane qui sont à 1 13
je savais qu'on était donc voilà je suis
né un 13 mai après tout c'est mieux que
rien parce que je suis sûr que monsieur
qui n'entrait aussi correctement
j'aurais pu ne pas exister
là bas je n'aurais peut-être pas dû
naître mère a failli faire de fausse
couche et nos débuts hilale a fait
croire j'étais vraiment pas motivé pour
séville métro boulot un pur vois
vraiment pas pourquoi
plus sérieusement quand j'étais enfant
je me disais si je ne devais pas être
humain mais que je suis là pourquoi donc
suisse comme celui là
marie plus personnel c'est qu'il ya peu
de raisons pour lesquelles je suis là la
première c'est pour avoir le courage de
l'erreur de reprendre le pouvoir sur lui
parce que bien souvent avant même qu on
soit d avant même qu'on ait compris les
règles du monde et comment il fonctionne
quelqu'un la société a décidé ce qui
était très bien pour nous à notre place
donc moi j'aurais dû être prof
d'allemand universités il est
brutalement a juste glissé
donc il se trouve que c'était pas
vraiment ce que je portais ce que je
voulais faire ma faute et changer notre
et même si je me souviens bien c'était
sauver monde et donc je suis allé
arracher la liberté le privilège de
choisir ma vie et pas vous c'est la
petite voix qui m'habite l'énergie qui
l'a amené à 22 ans à new york au siège
de l'onu comme correspondant de presse
puis à bruxelles à la commission
européenne
je voulais diplomate je voulais toujours
et puis ce sont des choses qui arrivent
je tombe amoureuse donc je reste en
france et cherche un travail et je me
retrouve dans la banque
et là j'ai vécu la crise financière de
l'intérieur aux premières loges au
milieu du bois la crise à frémissement
une lame de flo sa part mme
entrepreneuriat social économie du
partage
ça chante business sochaux pézenas on
est en 2011 et à michael porter année le
professeur de management de harvard
éminence de la place a publié un article
qui va faire date
en substance il nous dit que les
entreprises qui vont survivre au 21ème
siècle ne sont plus uniquement ceux qui
vont faire de la marge du profit mais
aussi celles qui sauront intégrer un
impact positif sociale et
environnementale et pour moi cet article
est une révélation parce qu'on n'a plus
besoin d'opposer l'économie et le social
parce qu'on a plus besoin de choisir
entre un train méchant qui fait du
profit est un gentil qui veut sauver la
planète et c'est à ce moment là qui
émergent aux etats unis le mouvement
débit corps l'ebit corp sont des
entreprises qui vont décider d'intégrer
dans leurs résultats financiers et
comptables les incidences
environnementales et sociales pour la
communauté de leur propre activité
les entreprises qui ne veulent plus être
les meilleurs du monde des entreprises
qui veulent
meilleur pour l'inde alors à partir de
ce moment là ce que je dis la nuit sur
l'économie circulaire collaborative
durable est ce que je lis le jour là
commence à faire le grand écart
alors bien sûr aux surfaces tout se
passe très bien géré des projets
internationaux
j'avais des équipes sur trois continents
je gérais des budgets de plusieurs
millions d'euros
et j'adore et mes collègues voilà je
voulais faire autre chose je voulais
faire changer les lignes je voyais le
l'état du monde et je me sentais inutile
sans pouvoir des gens mes fichiers que
c'est une carotte deux anglais un jeu
pas si vous connaissez c'est petit jeu
là qu'ils sont nés les boîtes à cuba en
général l'enfant doit faire rentrer un
tube dans un trou en forme de cube sauf
que l'enfant parfois décide que il veut
faire encore une étoile
et voilà pourquoi les branches de
l'étoile ne rentrerait pas et vota
pourquoi pas qu'il a décidé ça ne
marcherait pas j'étais un peu comme ça
tous les matins pour aller travailler
je repliaient soigneusement mes branches
les cinq branches de petites étoiles qui
vibrait de partout pour essayer de
rentrer dans mon tout petit cube tout
car écrit la journée ça me démangeait
j'arrivais pas à rester bien pliés comme
il faut moi ce que je voulais les
branches voulait se déployer ça vous est
déjà arrivé il a juste entre nous la lui
la main ceux qui sont déjà dit que leur
travail était pas fait pour eux je
voulais vous êtes dans le noir voisin
d'un côté qu'un événement
vous voyez neuf français sur dix sont
désengagés au travail c'est terrifiant
dont vous me levais tous les matins à 6
vous bravé le froid et la pluie ou alors
la chaleur et le soleil vous faites des
heures de bouchons de transport en
commun pour quelque chose qui n'a pas de
sens pour vous pourquoi sérieusement
sincèrement pourquoi est donc un matin à
matin tout rawkins entre ultime du café
et tu peux passer par s'il te plait je
lâche que je voudrais vraiment faire
nôtres le pressing de cette phrase une
journée pas la moindre idée
donc ce que je voudrais vraiment faire
c'est faire ce master en développement
durable parce que c'est là que sont
formés les entrepreneurs du changement
la zone et confitures la fraise ma
petite voix ou cette chose qui me porte
peut-être presque malgré moi
là on est sauf que c'est impossible
j'avais une carrière à mener
j'avais deux enfants j'avais un crédit
que j'étais quelqu'un de raisonnable
c'était impossible si parce que j'avais
oublié un petit détail
j'étais enceinte et qu'à cela ne tienne
en plus tout le reste je vais passer des
examens d'entrée et je vous trouvez en
scène plus de cette man à l'oral
d'admission
je crois vraiment qu'il
vu mon ventre rentré et là c'est là
qu'ils soient importantes qui m'ont posé
c'est parce que y arriver je vous sers
mon deux fois mon jeu pouvait pas
garantir à 100%
j'allais y arriver avec mes trois
enfants mais pourquoi je n'y arriverai
pas pourquoi on n'y arriverait pas et
donc je vends mon appartement je
déménage et je me retrouve quelques mois
plus tard le jour de la rentrée à
conduire une voiture pour l'apprendre
l'informatique tout seul à suivre les
cours de comptes à l'année tic en
anglais à faire ma stratégie à une heure
du matin dans les temps un bébé mais
pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça parce
qu aucune personne raisonnable ne se
serait laissé embarquer dans une
histoire pareille et pourtant c'est la
décision qui m'a le plus réconcilier et
je ne savais toujours pas et donc je me
retrouve dans cette dans cette classe
avec des étudiants qui veulent sauver le
monde
à costa ricain qui veut faire de son
pays le hub de l'économie circulaire une
gardiane mon ami ami qui veut qui veut
s'occuper des conditions des femmes en
inde
et vous qu'est ce que je peux bien ferme
je pars génère en énergie solaire
j'ai pas de projets humanitaires à
l'autre bout du monde
parce que mon truc à moi la
responsabilité c'est de tenir tous les
bouts avec mes trois enfants
c'est être là quand il le faut c'est
écouter les mots qui ne veulent pas
sortir se faire des petits plats bio
alors ma différence c'est que j'ai
essayé de cacher pendant mon année
étudiante et peut-être pour mon avis
professionnellement les spécificités ma
vérité le saute au visage ce que je suis
moi c'est une heure c'est une maman bio
parce que je suis peut-être moins 13 mai
je suis sagitta grandes idées au moins
et c'est comme ça que les projets lovely
famille pour aider les parents au
quotidien par de bons conseils pour
faire du bien à leurs enfants et à la
planète en promouvant les initiatives de
consommation responsable en s'engageant
avec des associations qui nous
apprendrons chaque jour les petits chefs
qui font la différence
et un jour vous verrez vous serez picore
ces entreprises du changement alors
peut-être qu'il vous vous dites c'est
encore un truc tous ces écolos moment
peut-être oui peut-être que non parce
qu'en 2050 il y aura plus de plastique
que de poissons dans les océans
alors peut-être que la pollution de
l'océan n'est pas dans nos priorités
quotidien mais le poisson qui était dans
votre assiette ce midi et qui a mangé
plastique
ils ont maintenant plus de la moitié des
vertébrés ont disparu depuis 40 ans
alors je voulais après vous qui prochain
sur la liste
les chercheurs américains ont tiré la
sonnette dernière mme cet été en disant
que finalement
aux etats unis les substances chimiques
impact sur le développement du cerveau
des enfants
un enfant sur 10 présentent des troubles
du développement c 17 % de plus qu'à dix
ans 87% des cosmétiques en europe
contiennent des substances qui sont
potentiellement à risques élevés pour la
santé des enfants
donc en fait on se pose on est cette
cause là
cette cause c max et la course que je
veux défendre pour moi il est
fondamental parce que c'est concret
parce que c'est tous les jours et parce
que ça concerne chacun
et donc ça commence chez soi devant une
couche navale qui sont presque la rose
et tous ces petits gestes qu'on fait
tout seul et on se dit que finalement ça
change pas grand chose c'est une goutte
d'eau dans l'océan qui s'est justement
parce que ça l'art de rien qu'il faut le
mesurer le valoriser et c'est exactement
ce qu'on va faire avec des outils
diagnostiques des défis environnementaux
et là vous dites non elle va pas nous
faire le coup de vous êtes tous ces
supers du quotidien je vous rassure
et donc ma révolution c'est la
révolution des petits gestes
un exemple je voulais faire plaisir ce
soir vous avez nettoyer votre boîte mail
un vieux mais cet espace de stockage
datacenter la moitié d'énergie d'un
datacenter
je sais d'électricité pour que la
climatisation
parce que le datacenter surchauffe tout
âge ont un petit mail à effacer vous me
direz ça fait pas grand chose si on est
timide mais en mieux
vous voyez la différence parce que vous
savez quoi vous êtes tous des super
héros du quotidien et donc c'est une
révolution douce parce que je t'ai clic
et recycler manger sont devenus des
actes politiques voire géopolitique le
choix de consommation sont des décisions
citoyenne c'est le nouveau pouvoir du
consommateur de vous de moi se reprenait
le pouvoir et si pouvoir changer après
tout la loi du business c'est que le
client est roi et le client chez nous
donc on arrive au moment où il faut
qu'on se demande
internet n'est pas une finalité en soi
c'est un moyen et quelle finalité
sociale et politique vous ne lui donnez
pour moi j'ai décidé de mettre au
service des causes que je veux défendre
alors aujourd'hui
j'écris ma start up pour les parents
basé sur télé ou alors environnementale
pour la consommation responsable
j'ai créé ici une association pour
promouvoir les femmes dans digital et
les accompagner parce que je suis
convaincu que le digital est une chance
pour les femmes et pour les mères et
puis ton parcours dans la banque
j'essaie de mettre au service de
l'économie locale en rejoignant course à
l'administration les banques sociétaires
avec un groupe de travail qui c'est de
voir comment on pourrait détecter en
amont les difficultés des petites
entreprises a manqué à soit huit équipes
pour la première fois de ma vie je
cherchais mes enfants à l'école
alors j'ai fait tout ça pour me
retrouver là je pensais que ce serait un
pas énorme
je pensais que c'était un fossé est en
fait je me suis juste retrouver un peu
plus loin alors j'avoue j'aurais
vraiment vraiment aimé pouvoir me
prendre pour le crunch était déjà pris
donc j'étais une excuse
[Musique]
et donc je veux dit si je ne veux pas
être là mais que je suis là monsieur
j'ai toujours un c'était une bonne
raison pour que je sois né ce 13 là
parce que je suis né un 13 décembre
parce que le très récent chili suédois
ces journées lumière
et encore peut-être que c'était la vie
qu'ils voulaient vivre en moi peut-être
qu'on a chacun quelque chose d'unique à
apporter quelque chose que nous seuls
portons quelque chose que vous seul
portée et c'est la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je suis peut-être que ce qui
nous fait peur des et marianne
williamson ce n'est pas d'échouer
peut-être que ce qui nous fait vraiment
peur c'est notre propre lumière
c'est ce que ça se pense ce que ça
changerait vraiment dans nos vies alors
maintenant parce que nés bien
voulez-vous demander c'est quoi un film
hier à vous qu'est ce qu'elle dit votre
petite voix presque vous emmène à
surtout qu'est-ce que vous allez lui
répondre on savait ce qu'on vous a soif
à ce que je vous propose c'est que ce
soir en sortant pour décider du premier
pas celui qui a l'air de rien mais celui
qu qu'il faut bien poser sur lequel tout
le reste ne pourraient pas commencer
parce que vous vous allez pouvoir et que
le monde vous attend
[Applaudissements]